as 2022 comes to a close I look back and
think about the games that have graced
the PlayStation this past year there
were standout AAA experiences like God
of War Ragnarok and smaller titles that
stole my heart like stray but now I want
to look ahead to 2023 and the promise
that the future of PlayStation gaming
holds even though a lot of these games
were on our 2022 list these are and in
no particular order so don't get any
ideas the biggest PlayStation games
coming out in 2023 and Beyond
[Music]
the next installment in the storied
series final fantasy 16 features
fast-paced magic and swordplay with a
combat system developed by Devil May Cry
and Dragon's Dogma veteran ryota Suzuki
the story follows the life of Clive
rossfield the son of an Archduke spread
across the different seasons of his life
and the ever-changing political dramas
and conflicts between his and other
kingdoms throughout the realm in
contrast to Final Fantasy XV the world
is not open to explore but will feature
large explorable areas throughout the
linear progression of Clive's tale dive
into the Might and Magic of Final
Fantasy 16 expected to launch in the
summer of 2023.
the Spider Boys Are Back and together
this time in the next game from
Insomniac we don't know much about how
the two Heroes will work together or
whether a specific symbiotic suit will
make an appearance all we know so far is
that Peter Parker and Miles Morales are
facing off against the slimy Venom
voiced by Candyman actor Tony Todd
Spider-Man 2 is expected to launch
sometime in 2023.
Final Fantasy fans are eating good with
yet another entry into the franchise
albeit a much more familiar one Final
Fantasy VII rebirth is the continuation
of the Final Fantasy VII story and will
cover the middle chapter in the trilogy
not much is known about the project but
the good news is is that the Final
Fantasy Godfather and game director
tetsuya namura has stated that the
development is progressing rapidly and
that the final entry in the trilogy is
already in development he also stated
that you can start cold with this entry
although Final Fantasy VII remake is
definitely worth checking out rebirth is
expected from Winter 2023 to early 2024.
[Music]
after seven years in development rise of
ronin has been announced as the next
action RPG from Neo and Wollongong
creators team ninja in koi Tecmo rise of
ronin has a combat focused open world
action RPG that takes place in Japan
during the bakumatsu period during the
19th century at the end of the Edo
period between rampant disease more
prominent Western influence and civil
war between the Shogun and anti-shogun
factions rise of ronin looks to depict a
dark take on one of Japan's most
turbulent eras along with its historical
fiction setting gameplay will consist of
a combination of the katana action that
team ninja is known for in firearm
technology introduced during the period
rise of ronin is set for release
sometime in 2024.
okay so let me get this straight for
spoken puts you in the shoes of Frey
Holland a fish out of water New Yorker
transported to the Fantasy Realm of
athia after being introduced to the
talking cuff on her arm she discovered
that the magical abilities that help her
Traverse and fight in this open World
adventure with her skills in quick
traversal and combat and even faster
one-liners Frey is the only hope for a
land that is in desperate need of a hero
join Frey on her journey to conquer the
evils of athia when forespoken Launches
on January 24th 2023
Konami is bringing us back to Silent
Hill developed by the creators of layers
of fear and the medium blooper team
Bluebird team is working closely with
the original creators of Silent Hill 2
iterating on the classic without
completely Reinventing the wheel with an
over shoulder perspective a rebuilt
combat system and changes to some of the
set pieces this remake looks to do to
Silent Hill 2 what Capcom has been able
to do with their Resident Evil series
remakes it's been 21 years are you ready
to return to Silent Hill if you are you
might have to wait a bit as the release
date hasn't been announced yet
the launch of the psvr 2 brings us a new
up close and personal entry in the
Horizon franchise Gorilla Games takes
all the climbing combat and big old
robotic dinosaur action that Horizon
does best and shifts the perspective
into the first person achieve Redemption
by reaching the top of the mountain when
both Horizon call of the mountain and
the psvr2 release on February 22nd 2023.
oh speaking of February 22nd 2023 here's
just a few more games launching with the
psvr too
just a few City's VR enhanced Edition
cosmonius High demio hello neighbor
search and rescue no man's Sky Star Wars
Tales from the Galaxy's Edge enhanced
Edition swordsman VR the Light Brigade
and tentacular
so yeah a light launch lineup if I've
ever seen one
remember last of us factions remember
how Flippin good Last of Us factions was
this standout multiplayer mode from the
original Last of Us is getting a
standalone sequel not much is known
besides some concept art but Last of Us
Creator Neil druckman has confirmed that
it will be naughty dog's biggest online
experience and will contain a completely
new story and cast of characters the
concept art details the San Francisco
setting meaning that there will be new
areas to explore within the last of us
Universe no release date but more
information is expected next year
in 2016 independent developer Yang Bing
posted a trailer for his upcoming
project lost soul aside it took the
industry and internet by storm so much
so that Sony invited the lone developer
to be part of the China hero project a
Sony effort to help Chinese developers
release games on the global market with
his newly founded Studio ulti-0 games
Bing has released an official
announcement trailer for lost soul aside
the game looks fast paced with a focused
on combat and platforming reminiscent of
the style of God of War and Devil May
Cry although we don't have a release
date yet Bing has stated that the
development progress of lost soul aside
is steadily progressing and we are
looking forward to provide more updates
and details soon
Spider-Man isn't the only superhero
under insomniac's belt the gruff talking
adamantium infused Canadian Wolverine is
getting his own game if the short teaser
trailer is anything to judge by this
game is going to be a much more gruesome
Affair than the adventures with the
Spider-Man the release date is set after
Spider-Man 2 so to be announced
originally known as project Eve Stellar
blade is the first multi-platform
release from Korean developer shift up
the story follows Eve and her Squad as
they work to reclaim a mostly extinct
Earth will you help the remaining
survivors on Earth rebuild their
Community or leave them defend for
themselves shift up has stated that the
decision is completely yours to make the
combat looks like a combination of Dark
Souls and Bayonetta combining fast-paced
action and massive attacks with precise
parrying and Dodge mechanics sorry PS4
players the game will only be coming to
PS5 sometime in 2023
it's time to connect America again the
surprise sequel to death stranding
brings back Sam and fragile along with
unshown newcomers played by Elle Fanning
and shioli kutsuna in true Kojima
fashion the first major trailer that
premiered at the game awards seems to
tell us everything and nothing at once
one major Omission though is a release
date so it may be a while before we find
out why there's a metal gear in our
death stranding game
bioware's epic Masterpiece in a galaxy
far far away is getting a from the
ground up remake on Playstation Aspire
Sony interactive entertainment and
lucasfilm games are all working together
to bring this beloved story to the
Modern Age with modern tech visuals
features and more although the project
was very early in development when it
was announced its release might be far
off with the announcement that it was
delayed indefinitely earlier this year
and there you have it from Epic Fantasy
tales and heroic escapades to remakes of
beloved Classics PlayStation fans have a
lot to look forward to in 2023 for more
PlayStation content and everything else
video games keep it here at GameSpot
[Music]